[Applause]
oh yeah
yeah
that's what I like
oh let it wash over me
happy Friday everyone and you know we do
on Fridays we welcome tonight's guests
this Texan just tested positive for
barbecue sauce co-host of Fox and
Friends Weekend will cave
this pyro lights a fire in my heart
co-host of fox and friends first Todd
Paro
oh
she's like a bass drum
she's like a bass drum it's like what
makes a lot of noise and gets hit on by
marching bands this contributor cat
Tim
Ing
and his forearms are the sides of four
arms my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tara
all right now before we get to some news
stories it's Friday so let's do this
[Music]
it's leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and as always it's
my first time reading these so if they
suck I don't care
here we go in an interview this week
former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie said he's considering running
in 2024
[Laughter]
the bad news he means for president
wow you could see that one coming much
like him
because he's big it's a nice way of
saying fat
plus size
a study from the American Society for
microbiology finds that New York City
rats can carry the covid-19 virus which
is in addition to rabies herpes and
switchblade knives
an avid marathon runner admitted to
pooping her pants because she didn't
want to stop while running a personal
best time it's the most inspirational
case of someone pooping their pants on
the job since the inauguration
[Laughter]
we have no proof of that
you guys love a good joke an intense
meeting two female Florida school board
members clashed over the definition of
the word woman and after hours of
arguing over who said what they realized
it's probably us
I can see that one coming
he predicts that the world population
could Peak at 8.5 billion people by the
year 2050. said one man hey if you need
help with overpopulation let me know
Intel Corp co-founder Gordon Moore
passed away last Friday at the age of
94. doctors pulled the plug and then
waited five minutes before plugging him
back in again
[Applause]
Moore's Law
a new virtual reality
simulator lets users experience what
it's like to feel their lives slipping
away users report this image as the last
thing they see
ah
plus the view co-host Anna Navarro says
she's upset 24 hours a day for having to
live in Florida not because of the
policies of Governor Ron DeSantis but
because Chick-fil-A is only open till
10.
[Applause]
say they had to perform surgery on a man
who got a water glass stuck in his
rectum after a drunken night out
the good news is he made it back to
Nepal just fine
that was unfair ah
yes keeping it on me a little too long
director
and finally President Biden's approval
rating has tumbled to just 40 percent so
to give his numbers a boost he asked
Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg to indict him
now the news obviously the bombshell
case that could have unprecedented
ramifications for decades to come
the legal victory for Gwyneth Paltrow
inner Utah ski Collision lawsuit
we go live to constitutional scholar and
Fox News contributor Jonathan Turley in
outer space
Jonathan what's your take on Paltrow
winning
darling can you hear me
seems to be in there
I guess our deep space technology isn't
ready yet
guess we'll do a different story
poor Jonathan
[Applause]
but he played along so who cares all
right the the indictment Trump's
attorney says he'll face 34 counts of
business fraud sources tell Fox digital
he'll surrender next week Alvin Bragg
was so elated he released a few extra
convicted Killers to celebrate
but Trump is ready to fight he's ready
to fight you know he's the toughest guy
I know I've never been more angry about
a charge because today the rule of law
in the United States of America died
it's dead it's dead it's dead while
former human being Nancy Pelosi
tweeted this nonsense no doubt from an
old Blackberry in her skeletal hands
quote no one is above the law and
everyone has the right to a trial to
prove innocence hopefully the former
president will peacefully respect the
system which grants him that right
well actually you corrupt old bat it's
not on Trump to prove his innocence in
our legal system it's on prosecutors to
prove guilt but that may not apply to
show trials like this or to comments
from a woman who was born before the
Magna Carta
I wonder what old Joe thinks about this
oh no no look look I suck gonna keep
saying it I believe in the rule of thumb
right rule of thumb
I mean the uh the thumb of
law and the rule of law come on
and it's like Nancy Pelosi said you're
guilty until proven innocent all right
that's the way our country works and uh
so this guy's got plenty of time to
prove he's innocent before he's
president again
no he's not president again I'm
um I'm president now right
yeah I'm president now so what are we
talking about here
meantime
Trump put out a very trumpy statement
quote the Democrats have lied cheated
stolen in their obsession with trying to
get Trump we're going to throw every
last one of these crooked Democrats out
of office so we can make America great
again now
as for Stormy Daniels which is not her
real name by the way since the news
broke she's making a killing selling
team stormy merch calendars t-shirts and
lingerie and as a bonus each item comes
in a free bag you could put over her
head
let's be honest
so what's this all mean well Bragg vowed
he would do this if elected so it's pure
politics but he has no idea really what
he just did he's like a suicide bomber
who just blew up his own party and that
party is the poor Democrats of course
the media is Giddy and why wouldn't they
be their dumb
laugh
who always missed the big picture
they've been hunting the same people for
years from parents at school boards to
Trump supporters to anyone with a
traditional pronoun hell Kareem
Jean-Pierre declared that transgender
people are under attack just days after
a transgender shooter massacred kids at
a Christian School
what's that tell you
that they really really don't like you
and it's no longer a left versus right
thing anymore it's inside versus out the
elite versus The Outsiders they look
down on people like you people like
Trump but don't get mad it's not worth
it just get your angry butterflies into
formation after all we can't run around
with our hair on fire you'll end up
looking like this
scary game
well
glad to see that we're all dressed the
same like uh vacationing real estate
agents
very strange
anyway uh do you I do you agree that
this is a political persecution do you
have any new thoughts on this matter
wow that's a challenge any thoughts
because everyone said everything exactly
say about this
um I think that maybe the most useful
thing to do is step outside of ourselves
here and hear it from the other side and
what they're saying is quote unquote No
one is above the law right what they
fail to recognize is that Alvin Bragg is
the one beyond the law this is a
misdemeanor charge it's statute of
limitations expired two years ago so
therefore it has other motivations but I
think the most important new thing to
your challenge Greg is that by Nancy
Pelosi I think it's easy to laugh it
away is the statement of an old lady but
it's not I think it's the philosophical
underpinning of not just the last five
or six years which is get Trump he's
guilty find the evidence later but it is
how they view the justice system guilty
until proven innocent
Todd you're actually a lawyer well so
was will oh that's right
not real estate agent now the outfits
make sense yes
we've got a bar meeting after yeah you
look you look like you look like uh two
lawyers at a bar at the Ritz Carlton
after a convention and your wedding
rings are missing
cat
anyway
they pile on these 34 counts we don't
know what's in the indictment that's
Tuesday so it's hard to make a
conjecture on this stuff is it possible
they just charge them for like every
Ledger entry like everything that said
like oh that's one that's two like and
it's all just one thing or that's what's
being reported that it is all these
different repayments but you touched
upon the law part of it and I think
that's what's so upsetting to me this
isn't about Trump this is about the rule
of law and when will and I went to law
school it wasn't that long ago but it
was probably around 20 years ago we were
in there with liberal conservative all
matter of individuals and there was one
common unifying theme we all believed in
the law and what it could do we knew the
law wasn't perfect but we all believed
that this was the American system and it
was better than any other I'd like to go
to bed tonight and say that that is the
case but if we're in a world where
political prosecutions are allowed and
allowed to go forward and potentially
lead to a victory for Alvin Bragg that
is extremely concerning and I know Trump
wants to throw that line up there if
they can come for me they can come for
you that's real we have to remember he
was a president and look what they're
doing that's true I'd like to go to bed
with Halle Berry
Cyrus the last time we had a political
hitch at Witch Hunt it was the
impeachment and covet just kind of had a
two or three month Head Start and I'm
thinking about this week and we have all
of these like techno nerds telling us to
worry about AI right and that instead
our entire media has to focus on this
thing and I have a feeling that our
robot overlords are smiling
I mean dying they got me yeah
I mean the one good thing is I guess
we're not seeing the face of the shooter
yeah so I guess that's nice yeah that's
true we stopped that little party but
you know for me this is just reaffirms
my vote like uh I'm I'm for certain now
that President Trump was the third black
president yeah very excited about that
and here's my case he's got baby mamas
yeah check
the D.A is always with them
and they're arresting him that happened
two years ago past the statute of
limitation so take the orange hair get
some cornrows
[Applause]
do you think it will add to a street
cred if he demands oh his street cred is
beautiful
but he's gonna he's gonna be giving out
I'm gonna free trains like this at Trump
Tower
this street game is strong should he do
a presser on two like so it's Tuesday
they're gonna walk him in should he
actually do the whole just stop and do a
presser you should do a pressure the man
ain't got nothing on me fight the power
do we do the fist in the air yeah I mean
you should do the do the whole thing
yeah amazing so Kat we talked about this
last night it's been 24 hours
um
any new thoughts insights do you think
do you think people are going crazy over
this or not crazy enough
well I think that obviously on this
channel there's a lot of people saying
this is political this is political but
I think the best arguments proving that
it's political is all the other channels
and everybody else because anybody who's
saying they're so glad to see this
happen they're not focused on this exact
indictment or this exact issue they
always say oh because Trump is he you
know January 6th or Trump is a liar
Trump is this and Trump is that which
none of that really has anything to do
in the eyes of the law with this
specific issue none of them are focusing
on this big specific issue except for
maybe stormy which is personal for her
and I can understand that
um but I just think to deny that it's
political is political because this is
an untested legal Theory it's a
coincidence they're trying it on this
guy yeah you're you're admitting that
there's all these things you hate about
him and that's why they're trying it on
this guy so I I mean I just think that's
just a fact yeah we I think what we're
seeing is a consistent pattern in
targeting people it's so funny too to I
know we got to go but to see that two
this week you saw Matt taibus on the
left and Trump is on the right being
targeted by the same engine yes and it
just shows you it is not left versus
right necessarily it is inside versus
Outside The Establishment versus the
Renegade and I know my Renegades hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you you will not get
it anywhere else